what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up again with
invincible now we're covering all of
volume 17 here but there's a very
particular reason for that right
normally we would split it up to make it
easier to kind of ingest all the
information that's happening but this is
a really really important one right this
one is the betrayal of monster girl so
one of the things that happens here and
this is kind of a crazy situation is
that one you actually end up learning
that dinosaurus is alive
the dinosaurs was believed to have been
dead now this comes during the events
when essentially adam eve runs up on
freddie mercury right because with mark
basically disappearing right mark not
being here and adam eve of course
knowing this is where he was last seen
as what isn't affect his wife basically
i mean she's his girlfriend but might as
well be his wife that what's going on
here is she wants to know where mark is
right and so of course we know that a
fight broke out between dinosaurs and
freddie mercury and that basically
dinosaurs had no real choice but to
start detonating parts of the ship of
the vulture mites in order to engineer
and escape for himself and mark and that
dinosaurs essentially was believed to
have been dead when he crash-landed on
earth but when adam eve runs up on
freddie mercury and then demands to know
where dinosaurs is freddie mercury
basically lies and he's like oh i mean
you know it was like his friend showed
up here and attacked and uh and and then
left with him and i have no idea what's
going on right you know if you want to
know where dinosaur or you don't know
where mark is go go find his friend
right go find that dinosaurs guy and so
following that you switch over to mark
himself right now mark of course again
is kind of recovering from the scourge
virus and the idea is that eventually
what happened when they arrived on earth
is that dinosaurs had just kind of
grunted a little bit and then seemingly
passed out and reverted back into his
human form and as you guys know when it
comes to the human form of dinosaurs the
only way to bring dinosaurs back is to
basically just bore the hell out of this
guy
it's the only way to make it work and so
of course that's exactly what mark does
while that's happening adam eve actually
hits up alan the alien and oliver as
well as basically zandale right the fake
invincible at the moment and then tells
him what's going on right like they need
to go find mark and so when mark just
starts boring the hell out of out of
this guy and basically brings back
dinosaurs this suit almost immediately
after that happens mark of course asks
the question why did general thrag try
to kill me like what's going on and
dinosaurs doesn't really have much in
the way of answers remember he didn't
really even get any answers and so he's
being honest here for the most part when
he tells mark like i do not know why
freddie mercury tried to kill you like i
don't really know exactly why that
happened but what you end up getting
here is of course zandale and then
oliver and uh and alan alien who all
show up here attacking dinosaurs and for
the most part of course dinosaurs again
is basically a good guy here but as you
would expect he basically defends
himself now as to the question how did
this guy survive we're given a cool
answer here that whenever some kind of
catastrophe takes place right dinosaurs
is injured or whatever he reverts back
into his human form when he turns back
into dinosaurs he basically heals from
all his injuries right so that's how he
has like his claws back and things along
those lines because he completely and
totally heals now i imagine there's a
limit to that right so like if he
reverts back to his human form and then
his human form is killed then dinosaurs
won't be able to re-emerge right he'll
basically stay dead but in the midst of
this whole fight mark tries to calm
everything down he punches out on the
alien and in doing so totally shatters
his arm and so at this moment right now
mark is powerless right he has no
abilities whatsoever he can't fly he
doesn't have super strength nothing
right he is exceedingly weak now this is
when things get cool because while all
that's going on and mark is basically
recovering you end up having this
invasion where essentially the thraxon
race returns now from the perspective of
monster girl and uh and and really rex
which is basically just robot from their
perspective this shouldn't be possible
right the thraxions should be completely
and totally gone or at least a
neutralized threat they shouldn't really
be here anymore in the midst of all that
once this this thraxion invasion
basically launches that you have what
looks like kind of a head honcho who
emerges only for him to basically refer
to rex and monster girl as basically
being their son right or at least being
the son of of monster girl and so the
question is how in the world did monster
girl end up with a kid now at this point
we wind the clock back right we kind of
jump back here a little bit if you guys
recall at a previous point in time there
was a conflict that took place and
monster girl and robot basically ended
up in the dimension of the thraxions and
remember time passes differently there
time does not pass the same way it does
here on earth so years within the realm
of thraxion is only moments on earth and
so that's why as things start to pop off
right once they're once we kind of jump
back to the point when they were whisked
away to the world of the thraxions that
basically what ended up happening is of
course they were taken prisoner right
off the bat and the funny thing is that
monster girl constantly breaks free of
her confinement the reason being because
when they chained her up they basically
had changed from monster girl they
didn't have chains for her when she was
like a normal human girl so basically
she just shrinks down back into her
human form and she's too small for her
chains and then she basically gets out
but no one can really understand how it
is and she's basically making her escape
and so as time passes remember this
basically happens over the over over
just huge time periods right like what
would normally be what we consider to be
like a day or something like that like
it's decades for these guys right just
huge amounts of time pass and so what is
it taking place is that at some point
monster girl actually gets close enough
to attack the uh the thraxton royal
family which is technically the zak saw
royal family but she basically attacks
the royal family and when that happens
because she got so close it's obvious
they can't keep them chained up in some
dungeon somewhere and so what they end
up doing is basically sending them off
to what's essentially the capital city
now this references issue number three
of invincible where if you guys recall
that omniman during the first initial
thraxion invasion actually followed them
back through the portal and then showed
back up again saying that they were just
never going to be much of a threat again
we basically ended up getting the kind
of continuation of that story in a
separate issue where he basically
trashed the whole place right where he
literally destroyed their capital city
and basically left a message do not come
back of course the thraxions ended up
coming back multiple times leading to
this particular encounter here but rex
we can just kind of call him rex now
instead of robot he has this really
genius idea because huge amounts of time
has basically passed right 20 years 30
years which from their perspective or at
least as far as their aging process goes
is basically mere moments he's been
working on this gigantic plan that the
way the flaxsense work and the reason
why they invade other dimensions is
because they basically need other
sources of labor right just different
things to do and so because of that the
idea of the capital city being destroyed
by what they perceive to be a human that
it's only accurate from their perception
that a human be sent to the capital city
or at least humans be sent to the
capital city to basically rebuild it the
plot and the plan of rex is genius that
the actions of omni man will have spread
throughout the entire flagship empire by
now everybody will have known of the
earthling who came to the flexing world
and destroyed their home city even if
they're not brave enough to act on it to
rebel or anything like that that story
is there and that over time because of
the fact that that monster girl and rex
don't age at the same rate that the
flaxsens do basically they can basically
build for much much longer so while
they're being guarded essentially day
and night and they're the only ones who
are really here working on anything
while it's meant to be a kind of
punishment they actually plan on
improving the capital city and that as
the capital city improves and as the
royal family begins to realize okay we
can actually do something here they'll
start sending more prisoners to this
location and that what will happen as
time progresses keep in mind this takes
place over generations right but what
red wants to do here is basically
rebuild the entirety of the city but
also build things like underground
bunkers more so than that plant the
seeds of revolution among the various
servants and slaves here because their
numbers will grow as time passes and
because the royal family is very full of
hubris because they believe their rule
is absolute they'll never begin to
realize that the forces of these
prisoners right these slaves will
actually outnumber the forces of the
guards because they believe that the
authority of the guards is enough to
keep the slaves in check and so in
effect rex is building a rebel faction
he's building what are essentially
insurgents a giant rebel force that will
overthrow the entirety of the thraxion
royal army and so that's exactly what
happens that because they often work in
secret they work underground they have
these little tunnels that no one's
supposed to know about they've been
amassing weapons arms armament different
things along those lines and in turn
when the time comes they launched their
assault right they launched their
assault on the royal army and this fight
goes on for like a hundred years it goes
on forever and ever and ever and ever it
goes on for quite some time but during
all of this right during a lot of these
things that are happening a lot of deals
are being made right a lot of glad
handing's going on which is something
that you have to expect when you have
like a particular ruling family ruling
over large numbers of groups right if my
memory serves me correctly with
something like the roman empire for
example one of the big things that led
to the collapse of the roman empire was
its inability to maintain its size right
it literally collapsed under its own
weight that this little bit of a
fraction here a little bit of a fracture
there basically led to its collapse but
the important thing here is this
that making deals right having factions
work alongside you who wouldn't work
with you before all for the purpose of
taking down the royal army basically
expands the forces of this rebel faction
it makes them more powerful all of which
is done under the guise that we will
destroy we'll take out the royal family
and then when that's done we will
organize everything from there and so
this conflict rages but during this
whole time where the conflict is raging
rex begins to grow more and more distant
right he begins to kind of break away
more and more distance and it's small
little rifts that form between him and
monster girl that here initially they're
basically allies with maybe a little bit
of love interest thrown in there but the
more time they spend together and the
more time they realize they're the only
ones they can really rely on that a
romance began to blossom but this
romance was complicated by the fact that
monster girl cannot understand the
thraxton royal language she spent 300
years trying to understand it and she
just can't grasp it that her inability
to understand what it is that rex is
saying when he's in a room with other
thraxions makes her feel isolated and
alone that there are times when they
share somewhat romantic and intimate
moments together and then in turn a guy
a guy comes in and basically says like
the scouting party is assembled right
we'll leave as soon as you're ready he's
like cool let's go and basically just
takes off right the whole moment is
basically ended what is what's happening
here is that because of her own
inability to cope in the environment
that she's in as well as the actions of
rex himself that monster girl is feeling
isolated she's feeling removed she's
feeling left out now because this is one
of those things where they try to sort
of rekindle this romance and they even
make love for the first time right they
have like an intimate moment with each
other now when that happens it sort of
brings things back right it brings
things back and the reason why is
because when they were here right when
they initially launched this whole
campaign it was the thraxions are bad
guys because they invade other
dimensions and we have to stop the royal
family because they're the main bad guys
and like that'll basically be it it was
superhero antics right it was just
nothing really special but with them
being together intimately like that and
then forming that bond the motivation
behind why they're engaged in this
conflict is not to just cast off the
thraxton royal family now it's to live a
life together right that they have no
intention of leaving the thraxton world
they plan on staying here for as long as
they possibly can and it would probably
be maybe half a million years right i
mean like literally it's been a few
hundred years at this point and they've
barely aged today and so it's one of
those things where like they could be
here for quite some time but the the
personal motivation for them to be
together right to have a life together
for as long as possible ruling as
presumably king and queen or the very
least as as two people who freed an
entire dimension and would likely be
hailed as heroes it's very alluring and
so eventually the conflict comes to an
end the war is over right those slave
races that wanted to return to their
dimensions are allowed to but most of
them didn't that most of them had
basically been there for like
generations and they saw no reason to
leave and so one of the things that kind
of goes on here is that monster girl
shows a kind of affection towards the
flaxseed race those individuals who are
prisoners but they're being abused by
the the guards themselves that she sees
it as something that doesn't need to
happen right that just because they
conquered a civilization doesn't mean
they have to abuse that civilization and
indeed that's actually the proper way to
do things right the best way to
basically take down an opposing force is
to give the people that that force rules
to give them a reason to leave right to
give them a reason to basically make the
argument you're better here than you are
there right it's the ronald reagan what
is it ronald reagan jimmy carter
presidential debate from the 1980s right
is your life better off now than it was
four years ago that's basically what you
would be doing here right like you would
literally be creating this environment
where your life is better under our rule
than it was under theirs and that's in
turn how you rally them to your cause
assuming of course they have the courage
to do anything about their terrible life
but rex is looking at all this and and
from his perspective the kind of
affection she showed towards the
thraxions that's the thing that should
have concerned him right that's the
thing that should have worried him but
he didn't think about that at the time
instead once the conflict was over and
the war was done they were championed
right people saw them as just like the
ones who basically ended everything and
as a result of that rex is actually
elevated to basically becoming the
leader of the new thraxion race and what
he starts to do with amanda at his side
right with monster girl at his side what
they start doing is ushering in this era
of peace that for a time things are
great here right things are phenomenal
here but then small little riffs begin
to form yet again one of the most
notable here is that due to her
compassionate nature which is actually
the thing that's causing problems here
amanda looks at what it is that rex is
doing and basically keeping the royal
family interred by keeping them locked
away in prisons where they have been for
the last 15 years and saying like
they're never going to they're never
going to leave right like maybe we'll
let them out at some future point in
time when they pay their debt to society
but that's basically it i mean in
reality the smartest thing for him to
have done would have been to execute him
like if what you're looking to do is to
depose and replace a ruling family you
kill them you take them out that way you
never have to worry about them coming
back and if you've done your job
correctly and basically getting most if
not all of society to turn against that
ruling family no one's going to oppose
you you've got society on your side
society becomes your army right the
average person becomes your spy that's
exactly what mccarthy did in the 1950s
1960s with mccarthyism right like if you
see something say something that kind of
a thing right you turn society into your
weapon because of the fact that rex is
basically building a civilization it
doesn't really leave him a lot of time
to focus on amanda the way she wants to
be focused on now i mean what's more
important here right like the girl
you're with or building an entire
society that's left to interpretation
but amanda can't really seem to get past
the fact that rex building a society
means he doesn't have a whole lot of
time for her and so in the end when a
person in a relationship feels neglected
eyes begin to wonder and that's exactly
what happens because amanda comes
running in again after some huge period
of time that where it was believed the
thrax and royal family the zaxles would
be allowed to basically go out and do
their thing that what's happened here is
something called the zaxel work
classification act was passed which
basically prevents them from being able
to integrate into society because the
biggest fear that rex has is if the
royal family is allowed to integrate
into society they'll start sowing the
seeds of revolution despite everything
he's done to ensure that society would
basically be on his side and so because
of this amanda hates the idea that
basically the royal family is being kept
in turn they're hidden away right
they're basically being denied freedoms
that any normal thraxion would normally
get that in effect either rex needs to
like kill them or let them back out
there into the world now of course he's
not necessarily in favor of him killing
them but she sees his actions as cruel
and unusual and so what ends up
happening is that some of the royal
family actually end up getting guards or
getting jobs basically working in mines
in order to like feed their kids and
different things like that and that the
guards there know that there's really
nowhere else for this royal family to go
so they basically beat and mistreat them
right they treat them like slaves
because where else are they gonna go
right and so monster girl actually ends
up stepping in and basically faces off
against some of these guys and then of
course has a little bit of a moment with
one of the members of the royal family
and that's kind of it now this creates a
gigantic rift between herself and rex
because from rec's perspective he's the
authority here that her going forward
and engaging in an act like that
undermines his entire authority it
basically makes it look like he can't
even control his own house and if he
can't control his own home what hope
could he possibly have to control an
entire kingdom it makes him look inept
and so because of that he basically
begins to lash out and amanda and then
sends her away and so in that time they
do kind of make up a little bit they do
sort of reconcile but there's this
distance that wasn't there before and
the writing is essentially on the wall
right the writing's there it's just
neither one of them are really paying
attention but like it's basically over
but like try as they might they try to
reconcile here and there but in the end
it always keeps coming back to these
problems these irreconcilable
differences that there are individuals
out there that were loyal to the uh to
the zacks or to the flax and royal
family that rex will not give any rights
to that he doesn't see them as people
who deserve rights because they did so
many heinous things which could be a
justifiable argument now the other part
of this and this is where the nature of
being an effective leader becomes
significantly important it's one thing
to have the people on your side it's
another to keep them there and that in
the end right wrong or otherwise people
rely on the government to basically keep
them protected right that's what rex is
running into here that rex is running
into a situation where resources are
scarce now the reality is that resources
are scarce because the flax and people
as you normally see in a time of peace
just start procreating with reckless
abandon right to start popping out kids
all over the place with no real thought
to how those kids are going to get fed
right it's just sort of this kind of
back of the mind thought that well the
government will take care of it right
and that's basically it but when when
reality starts to set in and it's you
guys had way too many kids there's
basically too many people and not enough
resources then suddenly it turns into
well it's the government's fault right
which is usually how it works whenever
it comes to any kind of a organized
society that the citizens of that
society rarely ever take accountability
for their own actions instead it's
always somebody else's fault and so
there really is fault all around here
because rex did not anticipate this more
so than that what he's running into is
the exact same thing that the royal
family went into that's the reason why
the flaxsense started invading other
dimensions in the first place because
basically the citizenry were giving no
real thought to how much they were
procreating how many kids they were
having they were creating their own
problem and then blaming the royal
family for it so the world family had to
do something and that's where amanda's
kind of like i mean look we could
basically go to other dimensions we
don't have to launch an attack we don't
have to invade them but we can have some
kind of system set up where like we
offer something they offer something
that is basically a bargaining system
right that is essentially just kind of
an exchange system i mean if anything
can be true communism
when it gets down to it but you know we
basically have a system where we
exchange goods for services or other
goods but the response of rex is no
that's not going to happen so what it
does is exactly what you would think it
would it leads to basically the
descendants zol and zahl who are part of
the part of the zaxel royal family
basically attacking uh rex and then in
turn when rex says no like i lead entire
legions of forces there's no way you're
going to take my my entire kingdom from
me he tells monster girl to attack and
she says no and a fight breaks out
between the two of them and she allies
herself with the royal family against
rex and so once the royal family
basically re-seizes control that what
monster girl does and sort of a weird
interesting thing here she basically
falls in love with another woman turns
into her monster form and then sleeps
with her right and basically gets this
girl knocked up and so the entire time
that rex is basically held in this
prison there eventually comes a point
when monster girl seemingly breaks him
out and then from there rex ends up
retaking the entirety of the empire
himself right casting everybody out now
seemingly uh monster girl does this out
of guilt right that basically she
cheated on and so the reality is that
when she reveals this when she says like
i stepped out on you i'm sorry i made a
horrible mistake that in the end he
doesn't give her any real benefit of the
doubt he just basically walks away from
her you know when she's like begging for
forgiveness she's like i'm sorry he just
doesn't say anything and essentially
just leaves the other thing here what
rex doesn't know is that she got the
woman pregnant and so it's as weird as
it
sounds amanda turning into monster girl
basically means she's got like the dude
parts and then got one of the thraxion
women pregnant and so in response to
that because of the fact that her life
is seemingly falling apart and because
his relationship with amanda is more
important than him basically being a
leader that he actually ends up telling
her like i've chosen my successor we're
out of here right like this has just
been too much it's taken too much of a
toll on us you mean more to me than this
whole thing i'm going to leave this
thing in capable hands we're going to
walk away and that's going to be the end
of that and so that's what leads to that
moment when monster girl and rex show
back up inside the universe where you
know where invincible takes place now
there is a super important thing here of
course the son of monster girl and rex
is basically defeated he's not killed
he's actually taken away and basically
held as a prisoner which you know
monster girl tries to talk to and he
doesn't really want to have anything to
do with her and that's that's basically
it but an important thing here there's
two major things that happen here the
first is that you actually end up having
a moment where freddie mercury meets
with crick and the idea here is that
craig was basically instructed to
procreate with humanity but not to
interact with humanity right not to do
anything that would like save them or
hurt them or anything like that right to
basically do what he could to ensure
that like the vulture might wouldn't be
noticed but they could increase their
numbers craig as essentially omniman and
and mark had predicted has basically
began to fall in love with humanity as a
whole but he's also got a woman in
london that he's in love with right that
he very much likes to be here on this
world that he's still essentially loyal
to freddie mercury as much as he can be
but now he has something to lose he's
going in the direction of omniman the
other big thing that happens here and
this is huge is that back on the thraxon
world before they left when rex was told
by one of the guys right that was out
there that uh that it turns out that one
of the members of the zaxar royal family
is with child right this actual rebel
basically appears to be pregnant that in
turn rex tells amanda to excuse him for
a second and then he starts speaking
with the rest of the staff in thraxin in
case amanda overhears because remember
she can't understand the language and he
says like okay so it's true somehow she
managed to procreate with one of the
thraxions uh okay like it doesn't matter
right if you know where they are i want
you to hunt them down all of them i want
their entire bloodline erased every
zaxel royal is to be gathered and
executed there is to be no quarter given
there is to be made no exception man
woman child all of them including that
unborn half breed that grows within that
traitorous zaxel belly kill monster
girls kid with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end pretty
bleak ending thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace